now on the same triangle you might
notice there's another angle one of the
ones I mentioned before on this list
that's also hiding this triangle just
haven't measured it which ones hiding
six degrees is up here see that because
it's the compliment right do you
remember when we look at complementary
angles you've got a right angle these
two have to be complementary so if you
have 60 up there then you can use sine
cos and tan for 60 degrees as well sine
60 cos 60 and 10 60 what's sine 60 have
a look
now we're not thinking about from this
corner we're looking from this guy sine
is which pair of sides in ratio opposite
the hypotenuse so what's opposite for 60
it's root 3 and the hypotenuse is still
the hypotenuse so this guy is root three
on two
didn't we write down root 3 on to a
second ago which one was that it was
cause 30 because it's the complement
exactly look see sine 60 cos 30 they're
complements so that's why these two
angles are the two ratios are the same
by that logic you should be able to tell
me what this is without even look at the
triangle right what's the complement of
this it should be sine 30 right 30 and
60 are complements so therefore you
should be able to tell me cos 60 is
gonna be a half people do care about
tents there it actually is there is a
compliment of ten will come to it a
little bit later okay
you can't tell me that 10 60 years have
a look have a look
no it's something else that's something
else obvious under adjacent have a look
I'm looking from up here now so what's
opposite the 60 root 3 what's adjacent 1
so this is root 3 on 1 or just root 3
okay so you get these six exact values
for trig ratios out of this one
triangle we call this guy unimaginably
we call them a 30-60-90 triangle because
that's the size of all the angles
okay now I know right okay
now I said to you there were three
angles that have nice ratios I've done
30 I've done 60 so it's left now I want
you to think about this guy for a second
45 is special it's unique because 45 is
its own complement 45 plus 45 gives you
90 so if it's it's own competent then
what kind of triangle will we get we're
gonna draw a new one it's gonna be our
sauce Lee's very good can you draw me
that's not very isosceles let's try
again that's better can you please draw
for me an isosceles right angle triangle
it's right angle and it's isosceles are
any of the two sides the same Georgia
are any of them the same I'll take that
answer Xander
okay now I remember what I saw Solis
means got it okay so you've drawn a
freshly triangle it's the last one we
have to draw to get these values out of
it now you told me those isosceles right
you told me those isosceles so if one of
these sides is set equal to one okay
what would the other shorter side be its
isosceles so these two sides are equal
okay if those two sides are equal then
you can quickly with Pythagoras work out
the hypotenuse one squared plus one
squared is two so that makes this guy
the square root of two okay all right
now from here we can work out sine 45
cos 45 and ten forty-five in just the
same way as we had to go with these guys
sine 45 let's use this 45 for the sake
of it
what's opposite the hypotenuse this time
one on Route two okay now we can go to
cause 45 and do adjacent and hypotenuse
but we don't even need to because
remember I said well we thing about
confidence right 45 is its own
complement so sine 45 is the same as cos
45 because they have the same
complementary angle and you can go ahead
and you can confirm it
there's adjacent there's hypotenuse it's
still one on root two
so it's the same deal okay and so that's
why lastly when you have a look at an 45
tan is opposite on adjacent he is the
opposite here's the adjacent so it's
just going to be equal to which is the
other nicest and ratio you can get on
your calculator if you pop in 1045
you'll get one okay